we owe a great deal to President Clinton
and to the Clinton Global Initiative we
labored in obscurity for 18 months where
we created the entire infrastructure the
the board the team the the vision the
country entry strategies all the
pictures and as a new team in a new area
with a new idea we were all about the
substance but we certainly did not have
any sort of global exposure we didn't
have the kinds of global allies that
President Clinton and the Clinton Global
Initiative have represented and what
happened is that we CGI has an amazing
capacity to screen for some of the most
exciting and innovative ideas out there
both within companies and within
organizations and CGI found us and
within two weeks they had basically
decided to take us and put us on the
global stage and what President Clinton
did and his amazing team at cgi is they
took us and in the finale special
session of the Clinton Global Initiative
of 2008 with President Clinton on stage
alongside Tony Blair and several heads
of state and regional hit and regional
head in this major CEO in front of a
thousand people and a thousand press
they put us on that stage and President
Clinton spoke about the importance of
leapfrog how we're going to we plan to
reach 25 million low-income and
financially excluded people how we plan
to do it profitably how we planted it
with quality of an affordable product
how we plan to do it with amazing allies
like law firms like akin gump and Wylie
Rhine like actuarial firms like Quinn
diem like micro insurance firms like the
micro insurance center they they gave us
a platform for that for telling the
story and as a result we've had a
flood of interesting offers and
opportunities and we're eager to have
more but to flood in we've had exposure
in major media like The Wall Street
Journal like private equity
international that has really helped us
to achieve our profit with purpose
mission and CGI has subsequently
developed a feature story on us and Len
introduced us to all sorts of good
people including big think and the
amazing work it does so it's been really
President Clinton as in so many cases is
a catalyst for profound change as he was
with bringing the work of unasyn Grameen
to this country as he and Hillary
Clinton have been in the insurance space
and here the Clinton Global Initiative
has helped launch the world's first
micro insurance fund and we believe it's
the the beginning of getting hundreds of
millions of people the insurance they
need in in the world's least developed
and emerging markets so I cannot
understate the importance of what the
Clinton Global Initiative is done for us
and I know there are many other
entrepreneurs out there and companies
and nonprofits and worthy multilaterals
that feel the same way that this
platform rarely is unparalleled